ce clip de déchets golo du berry tu
voudras dorda et à la carte express la
compétition est grande entre ces six
applications de livraison des
obligations ont vu le jour il ya peu
près 5 à 10 ans en faites le pour les
plus anciennes par contre c'est vraiment
un phénomène qui a pris de l'expansion
de manière assez importante au canada au
cours des deux trois quatre dernières
années maximum au canada
ces entreprises devraient générer cette
année des revenus de près de 3 milliards
de dollars on parle de multinationales
qui ont des riens que le souk sont
implantés dans plusieurs pays à court
terme on peut s'attendre à ce qui est
probablement en train deux peut-être
même trois fois plus d'applications de
livraisons sur le marché québécois dans
les cinq à dix prochaines années
anatomie et catherine trois blogueurs
spécialisés en gastronomie met à
l'épreuve pour nous les différentes
applications
attention c'est parti
premier test il commande la même peine à
lui-même restaure question de voir les
durées de livraison et dans quel état
les pizzas arrivent en serbie arrivé à
5h50 une pub est arrivé à 5h30 à la
carte extrait savary vers 18 heures
livraison entre 17h48 18 heures il
utilisateurs types sont des gens qui
sont relativement aux jeunes
principalement de 25 à 45 ans parce
qu'il faut que la jeunesse est aussi de
pouvoir d'achat qui entrent en ligne de
compte
c'est sûr que je vais choisir une
application parce qu'il ya dans leur
optimisme chez moi quand j'étais petit
j'avais deux choix
la pizza ou le poulet aujourd'hui ce
choix là est décuplée voire même
multiplié par le facteur sonne si on
retrouve vraiment de toupie des bons
restaurants et sait pas au juste des
restaurants fast-food les restaurants à
font partie depuis peu de l'offre plus
haut de gamme chez hubert it davantage
pour le restaurant c'est vraiment notre
passion des volumes de ventes de l'ordre
de 18 à 20% des ventes qui augmentent
leur faire une application d'une récente
de cassel chez pirelli
on n'utilise pas une mais bien cinq
plates formes différentes
à partir du moment où vous avez fait
votre commande nous notre tablette avait
se met à sonner donc on va voir qu'on
est une commande on voit exactement
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme dans la
commande donc à partir de là on
l'acceptent
dès qu'elle est prête on prévient un
livreur et à partir de là le client est
au courant
via son téléphone que le livreur est en
route nos blogueurs apprécie beaucoup
les applications qui permettent de
suivre en temps réel le déplacement des
livreurs
il ya un petit compte de votre bien
d'appareils la première pizza au fil
d'arrivée
dorda h 24 min nous allons découvrir
ensemble dans la seconde ça c'est pas de
sa faute il a servi comme ça mais la
piste est à l'envers qui arrivent le
matin c'est fou leur odorat est la seule
compagnie à avoir livré la pizza à vélo
quand même pour une pizza qu'un voyage
en vélo programme plus belle je te
laisse noter que toutes les pizzas sont
arrivés plus ou moins tiède officiel ça
va pas bien
enfin côté de la carte experts statut
des nouvelles de quoique ce soit
c'est à la même place ainsi que ça va
arriver vers 6h20 faut quelqu es là
bonjour deux d'un coup parfait excellent
alors on a ce qu'est paix à la carte ok
parfait
francis bien aller chercher ma pizza et
est en route
ça vient changer tu mérite a dit apporte
avec elle en 2002 qu'à la camarde et on
attend toujours golo ainsi bail qu'elle
est jolie je dirais que c'est la plus
belle arrivée en dernier golo a quand
même respecter comme les autres
applications
le temps de livraison annoncée alors
pour la prochaine séquence catherine tu
vas te servir de tes deux habitations
pour commander des tacos et aussi du
pilipili d'état cornes d'accord ça c'est
unique sahraoui pour quelque chose au 4
mars
tommy une bonne poutine mon ami résolu
pour le deuxième test nos blogueurs
commandant six restaurants différents et
on compare les coûts
la première mesure 6 $ de livraison la
deuxième 2 fois tacot donc vain de la
livraison 3 d'ordre ou 3 9 9
tps tvq pour boire 3 total 30 et 59
soute attaque taxe livraison sur les 12
commandes de notre test
les frais varient grandement passant de
99 cents à 4 dollars 64 ce collection de
la livraison et frais de service à ce
niveau ça dort dash ajoute aussi des
frais de service et de services
onze pour ça nous aide à faire
fonctionner d'un âge mais notre plus
grande surprise est de constater ceci
mais souvent comparé les lignes les prix
mettant sur l'application c'est pas les
mêmes prix qu'en restera donc disons
majorer les prix mais quand même c'est
cet ennemi en succursale 10 $ à livrer
raison cette pratique a été observée
dans plusieurs restaurants comme ici à
la voix de 6 ribéry peary il ya une
légère hausse environ de 10% pour
compenser justement ces commissions
qu'on a payé auprès de chacun plateforme
les restaurateurs verse en effet une
commission d'environ 30% aux compagnies
de livraison
oui ça coûte cher mais étant donné qu'on
a un gros volume
on s'y retrouve quand même 30 % c'est
beaucoup dans notre corps on le
considère comme un coup marketing
parce que moi et opérations aussi parce
que avoir un service de livraison à long
terme c'est énormément de gestion c'est
du personnel c'est de la logistique
dans ce cas ci c'est vraiment du clae du
clé en main pour les consommateurs
tant que la concurrence ça va la minute
où est ce que le marché cessera d'être
en expansion
les prix vont recommencer à augmenter et
là ça commence à faire mal
ces applications sont compétition entre
elles pour des parts de marché donc
beaucoup de coupons en ligne c'est très
rare que je commande sans couteau me
suis aperçu qu'il y avait une
application qui a tout les 5 minutes
il y avait un restaurant différent qui
avait une offre spéciale mettons 20% de
rabais ou un trio à de leur dérober ou
les frais de livraison sont gratuits
c'est sûr que c'est un peu plus cher que
si on va le chercher ça peut changer
sans cuisine pour 8 $ de plus je me
semble être au complet du marché
[Musique]